hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be a Rickon Stark video all about
season six just careful for spoilers if
you're not caught up because some really
big twists just happened the director
answered some big questions so recently
we saw Rick and stark come back on Game
of Thrones
it looks like house umber has betrayed
the Starks and is now working with
Ramsay Bolton this is small John umber
they say that great Jon number is dead
on the TV show now the thing that drove
everyone crazy after the episode wasn't
so much Rick and stark being captured
because that really sucks OSHA may she
rest in peace also really terrible to
lose her but when small Jon number
throws shaggy dogs head on the table as
proof that he has Rick and Stark
everyone's like that head is not big
enough to be a direwolf said it should
be way bigger and led to all kinds of
theories people took it as a sign that
there was a number conspiracy thinking
that it was tied to the idea of the
Great Northern conspiracy which I'll
explain in a second but just the idea
that the umbers were only pretending to
hand Rickard stark over and if there was
some big battle they would turn on
Ramsay snow the problem with that is
that the director of the episode
answered a couple big questions people
were like hey you know this this head
isn't big enough to be shaggy dogs and
he was like the prop master assured me
that this was a direwolf's head so why
would the umbers kill shaggy dog if they
were planning on betraying Ramsay's snow
so I think they just want to present
small Jon number on the TV show is a
total who doesn't care anything
about his father's allegiance to House
Stark and just wants to get rid of the
wildlings so he sees an opportunity so
all that really does is just throw water
on the great northern conspiracy for the
TV show it can still totally be a thing
in the books the books are way more
intricate way more complicated where
more characters there's the manderlys
Lord too fat to sit a horse we haven't
seen a lot of those people that are
involved in the Grand Northern
conspiracy on the TV show yet and as we
talk about northern conspiracy on the TV
show you could really just simplify and
call it the North remembers storyline a
lot of people got bummed out after that
number betrayal does the North not
remember you have to remember that
there's other points in the trailer that
reveal them in other northern houses so
yes some of the North has betrayed House
Stark but that doesn't mean the entire
North does not remember house Mormon I
think will be one of those houses there
will be people that will help Jon Snow
and salsa fight the Bolton's but I think
for the TV show just for the TV show
they wanted to see more like an even
fight like if you think about the books
the veil can raise 45,000 troops the
north can raise a little bit more than
that so you add in the wildlings from
the books and it becomes this very
uneven fight so I think in the name of
plausibility for the TV show they've
shrunk the numbers and they've even the
size just a little bit like you have the
snow bowl you have Jon Snow Sansa you
have ramsay on the other side they just
want Ramsay to seem like an actual
threat they don't want it to be
completely empty even though I think we
all believe that Jon Snow is going to
just ride right over him but what about
dire wolves our AP shaggy-dog I think
we're all hoping that the dire wolves
that are still alive like ghosts will do
away with Ramsay he's so fond of his
hounds feeding things to his hounds he
fed his dead girlfriend and he fed his
stepmother in his baby stepbrother to
those hounds so I think we can agree
that it's only poetic that he becomes
meat for the dire wolves that are still
alive we still have ghosts
we still have brands dire wolf summer
and we still have Arya's dire wolf
Nymeria but as of right now Nymeria is
still in the Riverlands running around
with the super pack because of her size
and her power she's become this super
alpha and has like a super pack of
wolves that follow her a pack that's way
bigger than a normal pack of wolves no
idea if the TV show is gonna do that but
another big difference between the show
in the books is this grey northern
conspiracy goes all the way down to the
river lands in the books way more people
the TV show is really keeping this up in
the north
like Littlefinger in the Vale is the
closest connection that we have and
that's only because he is so closely
connected with sonses character
otherwise everybody else probably
wouldn't be paying attention to it
they'd be more worried about what's
going on in King's Landing oh my god I
look the Queen's gonna be walking naked
through the streets let's talk about
that so given that we're only about
halfway through the season there there
could be some more evidence that people
will turn against Ramsay I do like the
idea of the evil turns against itself so
there might be a number of reasons why
Ramsay's army falls apart like there
could be people that just abandon him
mid-fight like we don't want to die
screw you guys we're going home
but I don't think that it's going to be
tied to the idea of the Grand Northern
conspiracy
so if shaggy-dog is dead though what
does that mean for Rick and Starks
future on the TV show
is he gonna die they already killed OSHA
so his days are numbered and Ramsey is
really unpredictable you can't trust
anything he says so I definitely think
that richens chances of dying went up to
like 80% on the TV show there's still a
part of me that's like maybe you know he
might make it out but I do feel like the
show could kill him and it wouldn't
destroy any future plotline because
think about what's happening Sansa wants
to retake her home so what would happen
if they were successful she would
probably live there and rule his warden
s of the North Jon Snow even if he's
part Targaryen before she came along he
was totally ready to go on vacation for
the rest of his life just like beasts
I'm out of here
so when they retake Winterfell and I
definitely think they will I think Sansa
is gonna be the one to rule there to let
you know leaving Jon Snow free to go off
and do something else but you have to
remember that this is just a step on the
ladder up to the war for the dawn like
things are just getting crazier and
crazier as the season gets on so even
though there's this big snow bowl that's
shaping up for the end of the season
that says nothing about what's going to
be happening with the fight against the
White Walkers but here's my big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
what do you think is gonna happen to
Rick and Stark this season do you think
that he's gonna die and when do you
think we're gonna see the first big
battle against the White Walkers now I'm
not talking about bran visions I'm
talking about actual battles south of
the wall I wouldn't be surprised if we
got a teaser at the end of the season
but it sounds like the biggest battle at
the variant like it episode 8 episode 9
kind of battle is gonna be snowball
stuff I think most of the season will be
consumed with that but what's gonna
happen next is there's a whole bunch of
stuff I'm catching up on there's some
new Star Trek there'll be new Game of
Thrones on Sunday I'll do another bonus
video so if you have any requests just
let me know in the comments and there is
new round of the giveaway so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video next
video should be that Star Trek video
it's almost like the Jon Snow prayer
circle from the beginning of the season
is turning into the Rick and prayer
circle so say your prayers for Rickon in
the next couple of episodes but why you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for my episode 4 video
and you can click here to learn all
about what's going on with Thor 3 they
just announced a whole bunch of cast
members thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you